[Musique]
les copains affligés les copines en
pleur la boîte à dominau enfouille sous
les fleurs tout le monde équipé de sa
tenue de deuil la farce était bien bonne
et valit le coup d'œil les quatzars
avaient fait les choses comme il faut
l'enterrement paraissait officiel bravo
le mort ne chantait pas à ce qu'on
s'enmerde iici il prenait son trépa à
cœur cette fois-ci et les bons hommes
chargés de la levée du corps ne chantai
pas non plus saint etlois bande encore
les catzars avaient fait les choses que
comme il faut le Macabé semblait tout à
fait mort bravo ce n'était pas du tout
des filles
enu avec des fesses à claque et les
chapeaux pointus les commèes choisit
pour les cordons du poil et nul ne leur
criait à poil à poil à poil les catar
avaient fait les choses comme il faut
les pleureuses sanglotaient pour de bon
bravo le curé n'avait pas un goupillon
factice un de ces goupillons en forme de
fallus et quand il y a là de ces dé
profondiss l'enfant de cœur réplic pas
moronbus les cadzars avaient fait les
choses comme il faut le curé ne venait
pas de camaré bravo on descendit la
bière et je je fus bien déçu la blague
maintenant friser le mauvais goût car le
Mor se laissa jeta la terre dessus s'ans
lever le couvercle en s'écriant cou les
quatzars avaient fait les choses comme
il faut le circueil n'était pas à double
fond bravo quand tout fut consommé je
leur ai dit messieurs allons faire à
présent la tourné des boxons mais ils
m'ont regardé avec de pauvres yeux puis
ils m'ont embrassé d'une étrange façon
les quatzars avaient fait les choses
comme il faut leur compassion semblait
venir du cœur bravo quand je suis
ressorti de ce champ de navée l'ombre de
l'igie pas à pas me suivait une petite
croix de trois fois rien du tout faisant
elle seul de l'ombre un peu partout les
quatzars avaient fait les choses comme
il faut les revenants sans mêler à leur
tour bravo j'ai compris ma méprise un
petit peu plus tard quant allumant ma
pipe avec le fer part je m'aperçu que
mon nom comme celui d'un bourgeois
occupé sur la liste une place le choix
les catzars avaient fait les choses
comme il faut j'étais le plus proche
parents du défunt bravo adieu les faux
tibias les crânes de carton plus de
marche funèbres au son des mirlitons au
Grand Bal des cadzars nous n'irons plus
danser les vrais enterrements viennent
de commencer nous n'irons plus danscer
au bal des czar viens pépè on va se
ranger les
corbillard nous n'irons plus dans au
Grand Bal des cas bien pépère on va se
ranger des
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
corill